the thing is like in particularly with
women i think our personal and
professional lives are
so inherently intertwined um and you
know
platform decisions and discussions tend
to be siloed into like this is personal
versus this is
professional
[Music]
rebecca bastian thank you for being on
my show how are you i'm good thanks for
having me
you're calling from seattle right that's
right wonderful wonderful
so you know i can't wait to hear about
your journey all the way from you know
your college years
to becoming a vp at zillow after 15
years of being there both of product and
community and i'd love to understand
how the two things intertwined because
both of them seem so crucial today
especially you know as community people
have been talking about building a
community within culture within
companies
for so long so i'd love to hear about
this journey all the way to
writing a book blaze your own trail and
to founding a company
way too much to go over in 20 minutes
but we'll try rebecca take me back to
your college days because you actually
have a pretty interesting story
starting from your college days so i
i think i went to five colleges total i
yeah the first one the first one was a
small liberal arts school
in high school and i actually failed out
of that i went for music
um and just just wasn't feeling it at
the time i guess wasn't was
didn't really have my act together and
um
and then after that i moved up to
seattle with an ex-boyfriend and
after working for here ended up
enrolling in the community college
um i chose a couple different community
colleges here and then
transferred into university of
washington for undergrad
mechanical engineering and then
ultimately ended up
also getting my masters in mechanical
engineering from uc berkeley
so a lot of educational trends
right so you know on one hand you're
saying an entrepreneur
and a published author a vp at zillow
one of the most well respected companies
and startups
in the united states in the world going
to five different colleges and failing
out of the first one
what was that about what what what
happened there
well you know i think um it's all part
of the winding path you know that's
something
that um i've certainly lived my whole
life is that it hasn't been linear
and it hasn't always been
intentional even you know where i ended
up but that's that's what i think is
important to talk about
and um you know i think when you dig
a lot of people that you might think are
you know in successful places in their
lives it turns out that it's not always
linear
and um i think that being authentic
about that
has like so many times when we're in one
of those
kind of rough patches or screwing
something up or
you know some something's not feeling
and i look around and we see
what seems like a bunch of really kind
of polished end results we can feel like
we're getting it wrong
because of that that winding one of the
things
i've tried to do and you know the
conversations i have and now in
what we're building with own trail is is
really kind of
embracing that upwinding journey because
it's it's not wrong it leads to some
really interesting places
amazing okay so before we go on to this
winding path non-linear
career pathways and and overall
mentorship
within own trail i'd love to talk a
little bit about your experience with
zillow
you know zillow it's one of my favorite
companies i i mean
it's i i've loved the transition that's
happened and back at stanford i
actually spent quite a meaningful time
with some of the machine learning team
to understand a little bit better about
this estimate and what's happening there
but i'd love to hear what was it like
spending 15 years
at a fast growing company going to to be
a vp of product
and vp of community so so talk to me
about the whole experience
but then also these two positions that
you've helped yeah i mean
short answer it was super fun i was i
i was one of the first employees it was
stealth startup when i started there
and um which is exciting in and of
itself
you know moving living more about again
now in a different
[Music]
you know we we grew in some
some really meaningful ways you know
also not totally whether we tried
something
and you know kind of you know made some
different
turns in what we were building and how
but like
a lot of it was just you know we had
kind of guiding beginning and a really
meaningful space to be working in you
know around housing
and it was really fun to to grow with
the company and you know when i started
there i was
i went for a couple few years before
that but i was still pretty junior in my
career and so i started as
you know pretty pretty junior program
manager and then
kept saying yes to things and raising my
hand and trying new things and working
on a lot of different areas of the
product
and starting initiatives and you know
grew through
into the vp of product role and
loved that it was really fun but then um
what i what i ended up doing after a
while until i
started taking on just a lot of slide
projects that were really aligned with
what i was passionate about so that was
really you know thinking about how we
create social impact in the building and
how we
um you know create more diversity in our
tech org
and how you know we have this great
culture from the beginning organically
how do we foster that as we really grow
into a bigger company
and so right what are some of the like
the biggest memories that you've had
like looking at those 15 or so those
like the big aha moments or highlights
that you've had
within this incredible startup um
you know i think the the biggest thing
is the friendships i ended up with just
long friends there and really incredible
people
that that i have the honor of working
with um
the mobile apps were really cool that
took on as a side project when the
iphone first came out
wow some developers on you know what
would be
zillow's first mobile app and we just
did it on the side for about a year
it really took off and ultimately i
ended up getting to be the first
um product manager for
for our mobile initiatives and really
leading a lot of and that was really
exciting
um and then yeah starting the community
and culture team was really exciting
because that was
you know that was a brand new team and a
new initiative as well that was really
follow
my passions into an entire new area of
my career
so what what so what it what does entail
the role of a vp of
culture and community um so the way that
you know it basically i i created this
vision for what that team would look
like
and was able to hire a really phenomenal
around it and the vision was really kind
of
um had equity and belonging at its core
so like from the ground up it really
about creating
equitable opportunities and just
they belong in the workplace and and um
from there kind of layering on like the
ways that we culturally engage with each
other and in our communities
from there really thinking about how we
can be leveraging people's unique skills
and passions to solve bigger social
issues through our business and products
so it
um there's a little bit deep structure
kind of based on on my background and
skills but it was a really um just
incredible learning kind of incredible
opportunity to
to make a difference in the organization
and
i was able to hire an amazing team that
i really learned a lot from
so the idea was that as vp of cold front
and and community this was an internal
within zillow how do you foster
creative collaboration and within zillow
so
what what's some insights can you share
with with me as young entrepreneur and
my friends who are watching this
about creating a sustainable and healthy
culture within a diverse community you
know
obviously today and and throughout 2020
this whole notion of diversity and
acceptance and culture has been
so monumental to our to all of our lives
and for everyone here
so what are some things that that you
learned throughout this
throughout these years at zillow that i
can take on with me
you know a lot of kind of our philosophy
behind you know how we
how he builds and structures it
none of this work is something that can
be like carried out and done by a single
team or by a few people it really needs
to be part of the company's culture
and so we're really focused on creating
pathways
for engagement from employees so it's
really saying like
you know fortunately we didn't have the
problem trying to get people excited
about this work
enthusiastic employee-based who really
wanted to
to do the right thing you know that was
part of our core values and
people really loved that and so it was
more about like
in the past four people to use their
unique skills
and their passions and get involved in
the way that kind of
you know feels right to them in order to
everything from just you know everyone
learning how to apply an equity lends to
the business that they're doing to you
know people getting involved with
um leading our fingerprints or culture
committees or
you know working on social impact
products or you know all these different
pathways for people to do that and i
think that's
a methodology that probably applies to
different companies but also a lot of
different
community efforts and um you know
anytime you have
a group of people that
change then it's about kind of creating
those pathways to do so in a way that
really brings people
together to um to create that change
wonderful okay so you go and you write
your own book and
it's a different type of book right it's
not just starting in page one and
finishing on the last page and reading
through the whole thing
you kind of jump around and talk to me a
little bit about this book and how that
inspired you to then create
your own venture own trail yeah so the
book plays your own trail
is it's an interactive exploration of
women's life paths
and so it uses the the choose your own
journey format which
you know is um childhood choose your
adventure books
and which means that you know you the
reader are the person going through the
story
and you make a decision at the end of
each chapter that tells you where to go
to
next so essentially the whole table of
contents is this big decision tree
and there's all these different pathways
there's 19 different endings
19 yeah nine ten different endings to a
book
yeah i i you know i i have to say that i
just finished writing
writing a book myself that will be
published hopefully next week or the
week after and i could barely think of
one ending so i can't even imagine what
it's like to think of 19.
and it's a normal fiction so it should
have been pretty easy
well congrats on finishing the book
that's that's super exciting
um yeah i think you know coming from
that that product manager kind of
happened i think
thinking trees so it becomes kind of
natural it's for me but
yeah it was really fun it's really it's
trying to you know create the experience
of like the different decisions we make
and professionally as women and it
leaves a lot of data into it as well so
it is this fictional plot line but
with data really kind of creating that
sense of solidarity
that might feel like they're less common
because they don't get talked about as
much
but in fact are you know there's some
really shared experiences in there and
creating solidarity of knowing that they
were all going through a lot of those
similar things
and that you know while you know
oftentimes the outcomes of our decisions
and aren't what we necessarily thought
we wanted like we can be okay and we can
find
our our happiness through all the
different twists and turns
wow so how how long did this whole
process take from this idea of blazer on
trail until
the day that it got published um so i
wrote the first draft about
five months and um around the time like
shortly before i was finishing the first
draft is when i signed a contract with
my publisher
eric cole um and they were amazing i had
my my editor there anna was really
incredible and the whole team was really
incredible so i had a really positive
experience with that to
contract until it came out was a year
now
during that year you know i went through
all the different editing
and and rewriting stuff and then there
was a waiting period in the area to see
when owen trill was born i started
thinking about um
how i might create you know what i
thought would be a book launch website
um maybe something about the trails that
different women have placed
but it ended up really taking on a life
of its own
pretty quickly and we really found some
important thing and some big ideas for
solving them
around you know what mentorship has
traditionally looked like
and what it could look like if we were
able to scale
i and countless other women get asked to
to go to coffee and share what our
journey has been by
young women who who really want to hear
those experiences and get advice and it
just it doesn't scale we can't say yes
to everybody
and oftentimes you know we as women
especially women who
hold different multiple identities
um don't always have people in our
immediate purview that
that look like us that we that and that
could be really valuable to see
and so what we're doing is really
creating this skillable platform
that is an aggregate of what we call
microactive mentorship
which is women sharing the trail they've
placed through
connected milestones and we're combining
all those trails together
to be both this really rich
content you know stories essentially but
it's all structured by data so we're
essentially going to be building out
this huge neural network of life paths
that can be used to really answer the
question
provide the guidance and inspiration
that women are looking for when they say
they they either want a mentor or want
to be a mentor
wow okay so so you know i have to say
first then you know reflecting back on
this
on this idea of decision-making trees
and there's sometimes this fear of
making certain decisions and the
different outcomes it can make
and i reflect back i'm a huge broadway
fan and there was a show that i saw
quite a few times called if then with
the dina vanzellon and the whole show
was about this character who has to make
some lifelong decisions and
and the show kept going through
different realities and showing what
would have happened
had she made those different decisions
but the but the bottom line of the story
was
that by not making a decision or by
being fearful of making a decision
then she was making some of the poorest
decisions by not making them
in the first place and and she was
longing for that mentorship throughout
the show
so about this need that that one trail
is trying to solve so
i'm understanding that the idea that
you're creating this big network
of different of different pathways that
people have taken you're creating this
community of mentorship where women can
seek mentors or they can offer
mentorship to others
what is the the pain point that that
you're out there trying to solve
that came as an inspiration through
blaze your own trail
yeah i mean there's kind of two sides of
pain points right because on one side
it's like
you know we we're worrying about our
paths through life worrying about how
we're
we're going to get there we need to see
people who look like us in the places we
aspire to
and we don't have we don't always have
that access to that
and honestly even when you get a
mentoring relationship like
you're never going to get everything you
need from a single person right there's
just so many different facets of our
lives and
i'm different you know situation that it
really
you know aggregate inspiration really is
so much more powerful
but like that and then on the flip side
is the fact
that we want to be able to coming up
behind us
but you know the the traditional ways of
doing that just aren't scalable so i
can't say yes to every coffee you know
even when i
even when i prioritize and so you know
we what we believe is that traditionally
when women say
they want a mentor or they want to be a
mentor they're really saying i want to
be able to solve
problems i'm experiencing um and you
know
75 percent of women we know aren't
solving those problems they aren't
giving or getting the mentorship they
want
so youth and trail is really reframing
what mentorship can be
in a way that reaches all women where
they are
when they need it and really both
provides the
of these different life paths but then
also provides
the the action and the framework to
really kind of navigate your own life
and
and figure out where you're going to
navigate that through the power of
community what does that mean that 75
of women don't have the mentorship that
they need
well basically from serving then like
have you
are you getting as much mentorship as
you wish you were or are you
providing as much mentorship as 75
percent
say no over 75 say no to both of those
and and so so so what your thesis
is that it's it's a matter of
accessibility that you know by building
a community of givers and takers or
that are all but obviously each person
is playing both sides of the market
right
and you're able to create this this
accessibility network
where where everybody can get the
mentorship that they're looking for now
are these is this mentorship
specifically professionally so these are
professional decision making or is this
could be anything
like i'm i'm i'll be thinking of going
on a maternity leave but i'm
i'm not really sure how my my employer
is going to take it
i mean the thing is like in particularly
with women i think
our personal and professional lives are
so inherently intertwined
and and you know platform decisions and
discussions tend to be
siloed into like this is personal versus
this is professional
and so you know we're really trying to
blow that idea open
and so yeah it is everything shared
are you know it's yes it's it's
different career obstacles that women
have navigated and accomplishments
there's you know
having been or fertility issues there's
mental health there's grieving
there's self-doubt there's unhealthy
relationships there's great
relationships
and it's really it's it's the
culmination of all those milestones that
really makes up what our real journey
looks like and it's not the
perfect linear path that we might have
expected
i love it okay rebecca so so two things
before we go first
you know reflecting back on the
incredible experiences you've had
going to five different colleges and i'm
calling that an incredible experience
that probably very few people have so
and i'm sure that there's a lot to take
from there as well and all the way to
you know being vp at zillow and working
for 15 years to writing a book to your
own company
what are some really key takeaways that
i could take from for myself
or from my friends as we are just
starting on our journey right where i
mean i'm just in college now so
what what are some things that i should
be keeping in mind that that you would
recommend for me
well i really like this this framework
that i recommend sometimes to people
because
it is
getting in terms of you know having your
your eyes on some far away vision and
it's really you know
at any point in your life thinking about
are the things in my life that are
giving me the most energy like where are
my passions what's fueling me
and what am i good at right and that's
not necessarily like
for the job titles you've had but it's
like what are those comparing
sorry
[Music]
and sometimes it's as simple as like
there's this job description and you
apply to the job but sometimes where
you're needed is a little bit you know
requires a little
more creativity and you know you have to
see that there's a problem to be solved
and you're the person to solve it but
the advice really would be you know if
you triangulate those three things
your skills and your passion and where
you're needed
and use that to really guide what what
you do
and where you go next i think that it
will open up some
interesting opportunities and
experiences in your life
i love it rebecca right before we go i
want to thank you for being so generous
with your time this was really really
fantastic
i need three words that you would use to
describe yourself
um okay i would say creative
okay i'm excited
i get i get excited about a lot of ideas
and um well
hyphenated word risk taker creative
excited and risk taker i love rebecca
thank you very very much
owen trail and blazer on trail and you
also have a crowdfunding campaign that's
active and i believe it has a few days
left well by the time that this gets
aired
it will already be over but it'll be
successfully over and i think it's like
like right there right it's like right
there yeah we're we're at
95 right now so we're very 95 yeah
yeah i would love for everyone everyone
listening that identifies as a woman to
share your trail on owntrail.com
and everyone listens to the women that
you know that are inspiring and ask them
to do so and
it's it's a group effort so yeah i love
it
rebecca thank you very very much and and
stay safe and stay healthy
thank you you too thanks for having me
thank you